the Joe Rogan experience yeah I gotta
get you on some science documentary oh
yeah when you're smoking weed and watch
that science documentaries that'll help
my music listen the real thoughts come
out kids well you realize there's no
getting away if you if you you know that
paranoid feeling that you get sometimes
you get too high if you have that
paranoid feeling combined with a science
documentary on space hmm then you
realize yeah we're we're all very
insignificant exactly and you seem extra
high because you're high watching space
yeah it's like you're to do this stars
how have you gotten high your whole life
I started when I was 16 when you were 16
mmm I started smoking every day wow
they're so right around the time where
you were becoming successful as a rapper
mm-hmm it was really like high school
because I hated school and I was just so
done with it and I was selling pot and
my mom found out and she was low key
just super cool when it was like like I
smoke you smoke
we smoked and you mean wow
it actually helped me get through school
like to make it made it tolerable like
sure I was able to deal with like the
[ __ ] that I didn't want to do it because
I'm an intelligent kid I just really
didn't like school I didn't like the
school that I went to was good I went to
a nice school but it was just I grew up
in a time where it was like mmm saying
was we're so well every school for every
kid it's not what you want to do every
day it was just not what you want to do
every day and like you got teachers who
say certain things to you and it's like
all right I understand what I'm really
here for you know I mean and I see Who I
am to you and you let it be known it's
kind of hard to like take those people
serious and want to do the work and all
Russians want to follow their lead
yeah that's like for me that was the
bare minimum was like graduate high
schools like I could move on with the
rest of my [ __ ] life after that yeah
we'd help me get through high school
okay everybody help me
I believe you yeah it makes sense yeah
there's a lot of [ __ ] that's not that
fun but when you're high becomes
interesting a lot of [ __ ] yeah yeah it's
why air travel air travel is always
better when you're high way better way
better and you could take THC pills you
got edibles you do whatever you will
come like appreciative of the experience
exactly yeah yeah yeah just be up there
flying for real yeah uh there's
something to me about music listening to
music too and a plane while you're high
hmm
just that it has like extra impact
putting headphones on a plane surrounded
by all these people no one's talking
flying through the sky going 500 miles
an hour and thirty thousand feet above
the rocks mm-hmm and that music kicks in
hmm